uh one two three test test test no
that's not your talk okay hello everyone
how you doing
okay so today we're not gonna do a
number by itself but a number that comes
with a friend
and two
eight
four
these are called amicable numbers or
friendly numbers okay so why two numbers
friends well we're going to look at the
divisors of these numbers so what
divides 220
well one divides 220 2 4 5
20 22 44 55 110
and 220 itself but we don't include 220
itself not the number itself so we take
these numbers here
and if we add them up
we're going to get
284 but if we do the same thing for 284
what divides 284 1 2 4 71 divides
142.
if we take those numbers
and add them up we get
220. so the divisors of 284 add up to
220 and the divisors of 220 make two
eight four
so they come as a pair that's friendly
that's for my petitions that's friendly
these aren't the only numbers but this
is the smallest pair of numbers that do
this now these numbers were known in
ancient times and in those days they
like to give numbers properties and
these numbers would represent perfect
harmony mutual friendship and love
so
two lovers would inscribe 220 and 284 on
talismans and you would wear one
talisman and you will give the other
to your lover a story i like so much i
even had 220 and 284
inscribed on
talismans of my own why have you got
both of them shouldn't your lover have
the other half
yeah thanks for pointing that out thanks
for bringing that up and there's 220
still looking for my 284. so these were
known in ancient times
a few more were known after after that
actually in the 17th century it was the
17th century mathematicians who started
to look for some more of these but what
i like about this is that they missed a
pair
in fact they missed the second smallest
pair of amicable numbers and these were
found
200 years later in the 19th century by
16 year old italian schoolboy
who found the second smallest pair of
amicable numbers which are about
1184 and
you can work the other one out for
yourself
however
their best use is probably their
original one
when two lovers would inscribe the
numbers 220 and 284 to two halves of a
fruit
and then they would split the fruit
and one you take one half of yourself
one half for your lover and by consuming
the fruit you become complete
ah
that's lovely
i've got an apple out here somewhere
oh it's got a hole in it that'll do it
all right yep do the same thing for 284
and you'll get 220. don't cut yourself
by the way 220 can you see oh yeah
and 284 just about
who i'm going to get the other half to
[Laughter]
no one's taking it